We've congratulated ourselves for getting this far. We've still got a ways to go.
Now the question is what do we do next?
It may seem a little bit daunting, but there's so much to do, and when I get that feeling,
I remembered the book Bird by Bird by Anne Lamott, a very funny book.
In it, she relates the story of how when she was in elementary school and there was
a big book report due where she had to write up descriptions of multiple different birds.
And she was behind and it was due soon, and she went to her father and complained,
"How am I ever gonna get done. I'm behind," and her father just told her, "Bird by bird."
"Just go and take the first bird, write up a report on that, and then
take the next bird off the list and keep continuing until you're done."
Let's go bird-by-bird and finish this up. What do we have left to do?
Well, we got to figure out how to put letters on one particular row while dealing with the crosswords,
then we got to expand from that to all the rows and then we got to do the columns as well,
and then we got to worry about the scoring.
There was a couple of minor things to be put off like dealing with the blanks.
That's a lot to do, and let's go bird-by-bird .